hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar the three-peat challenge for
long red ultra deep stool metagenomics
on the Promethean i am michelle ashton
of laberd's and I'll be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is presented by laberd's and
brought to you by z moly search by mo
research is a privately owned company
that has been proudly serving the
scientific community with
state-of-the-art molecular biology tools
since 1994
the beauty of science is to make things
simple as a mantra that is reflected in
every cyma research product from
epigenetics to DNA RNA purification
technologies historically recognized as
the leaders in epigenetics today's Imoh
research is breaking boundaries with
innovative solutions for microbiome
measurements DiMeo research is the first
company to develop micro bio mix
solutions from collection to conclusion
based on new rigorous standards for
microbiome measurements DiMeo research
has been leading the initiative to
improve reproduct ability and accuracy
in the field by developing the first
commercially available microbiome
standards
more about our sponsor please visit
www.mptv.org/outdoorwisconsin your
screen this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located at the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits I now present today's speakers
dr. Joshua quick research fellow at the
University of Birmingham in the UK and
dr. Yanina Crum Beck the director of
microbiome applications at Vienna
research corporation for the complete
biography on our speakers please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen our speakers will now begin their
presentations
hello my name is dr. Joshua quick and I
work at the University of Birmingham in
the United Kingdom and today I'm going
to present to you a title named a talk
titled
the three peaks challenge for long read
contra deep still metagenomic on the
Promethean
right
for sequencing is a relatively new
technology it was brought to market only
in 2015 and it's a it's notably a long
read sequencing technology it's the
second of two long read sequencing
technologies after patch by sequencing
and what that means is that you're able
to sequence very long molecules which
are important for for things like de
novo assembly up until now the yields
from these instruments has been quite
limited but with the introduction of the
Promethean in the last couple of years
the opportunity has arisen to generate
very large long read datasets and that's
exciting because it allows you to
increase the understanding of complex
and microbial communities and this is
generally known that they're generally
at an area known as metagenomics so we
particularly have two clinical
translational projects here in
Birmingham that we were interested in
applying this technology to the first is
equal microbiome transplants which are
being used more and more for the
treatment of chronic c diff infection
our particular study is looking at the
effectiveness of fecal transplants in a
different condition called ulcerative
colitis and in that particular project
where we're looking at the microbial
community of the human gut before and
after transplantation we have a second
project where we're looking at the
respiratory microbiome of cystic
fibrosis patients and this is a chronic
lung condition and the the and it
evolves over time and we're interested
in looking at the evolution of the
respiratory microbiome in the disease so
that the particular detail of the things
that we're trying to do is that we're
trying to enable a single contech de
novo assembly and that basically means
taking a very complicated mixture such
as the human gut and using long reads
being able to novo assemble you know
short you know entire bacterial genomes
from
that complex mixture and this is this is
where where it comes back to the fact
this is only really been possible with
the with the with the introduction of
the premiere car and being able to
generate very large data sets of long
reads because human gut contains many
hundreds of individual bacterial species
are quite wide range of abundance and in
order to be able to assemble whole
genomes from those you need to produce
sufficient coverage from from those
organisms to be able to assemble them so
we're trying to be able to link genes to
chromosomes we're trying to be able to
identify strain level variation using
habit typing in in the case of of things
like the evolution of the system of the
of microbes in chronic chronic
colonization in diseases like cystic
fibrosis but very specifically what we
want to do is to be able to track
strains from before and after
transplantation of the fecal transplant
search we want to be able to see if
individual strains persist after a
patient has received transplantation and
that and for that application de novo
assembly is very important to be able to
assemble those genes and look at that
variation so we've been working on ultra
long reed sequencing methods for a very
long time in Birmingham pretty much
since the pretty much since the
introduction with nanopore sequencing
and ultra long Reed sequences are
defined as reads over over a hundred
thousand base pairs because that is our
definition so long reach sequencing
typically is classes anything you know
above ten thousand bases and then ultra
long B hundred thousand bases the
requirement in order to achieve ultra
long lead sequencing methods you need
very high molecular weight input DNA and
the way that we originally did this we
actually did the human genome with
optional reads two to two years at two
or three years ago and the way that we
did that was using a phenyl chloroform
extraction method which is very
traditional
originally invented I think in first
published in something like the 1950
1950 six so very old method and this
particular protocol which I used came
from a very famous book called molecular
cloning by Sandburg which many people
would have seen if they live in a lab
but basically it relies on the detergent
detergent based lysis of cells digestion
of proteins by proteins k and then and
then removal of proteins using phenol
motions before ethanol precipitation and
the way that we were able to generate
reads over a hundred thousand base pairs
up to a million base pairs was using a
kit that Oxford nanopore developed
called the rapid kit and that is the the
kit relies on a method called tagging
tation which is which is done by using
something called a transpose transpose a
is complex and that is a protein which
which complexes with an with an ala
going in a wildcat trap this would be a
transposon which is and it is used it
facilitates the movement of genes
transpose arms around the genome this
particular case you use transpose on
ends and you can you can sort of cut and
paste the adapters into it into a genome
and it's very useful for producing next
generation sequencing libraries and the
way that we manage and really long reads
was purely by taking the standard and
kit and then putting a very large amount
of high molecular weight DNA in there so
to minimize the number of insertions per
molecule so basically saturating that
the number of transpose complexes our
first attempts doing this produced
dataset on e coli which had an N 50 and
n 50 isn't is a measure that we measure
of length of a read set of 65,000 base
pairs with a maximum of seven hundred
and seventy eight thousand base pairs so
this is clearly something which is a
be possible with the with you know
cutting-edge technology such as nanopore
sequencing being able to thread a
molecule nearly a million base pairs
through it to rapport is seriously
impressive stuff so from the pulse field
gel you can see on the right-hand side
of this slide we able to extract DNA of
two to three hundred thousand base pairs
using this phenol chloroform method from
e.coli and that means that even using
even the fact even if we have to to to
cut or insert and the the using the
using the transpose days we can still
get reads over you know over a hundred
thousand base pairs very easily
but it's very suitable for for for for
what we were trying to do back then
it looked me that the DNA in cloud that
insertion and still to still generate to
still generate long reads reason why we
chose this kit was actually because the
it minimizes the amount of handling of
the DNA which we found to be the most
important factor in can generate
inoculum reads
and this slide here is actually the is
actually the E coli genome represented
across the across the figure and sharing
eight nanopore reads which spanned the
entire genome with overlaps with an
average length of 750,000 base pairs per
reads so a piling path across the entire
4.5 million base pair coli genome from a
read and we able to assemble these reads
on a single core in one and a half
seconds and this is really to
demonstrate the power of ultra long
reads to be able to assemble genomes
rapidly and also to show that if you can
get rid long reads than de novo assembly
is a completely trivial process whereby
all you're trying to do is identify
eight overlaps this is there this is a
contrived example really but just to
illustrate the point of why getting long
reads is important and why it's
important in particularly in complex mix
has become more complicated than words
enable assembly and challenge becomes
more complicated for for human stool
extractions for doing for doing
microbiome stand studies we're not able
to extract DNA anywhere near to two to
three hundred thousand base pairs and
that has to do with the fact that
microbes you know in real clinical
samples have um you know there's a
they're complex samples containing a
mixture of viruses bacteria and fungi
they have very hard as so walls some of
them compared to the human and the cola
that we would we were demonstrating this
method on forms so instead of trying to
target reads two to three hundred
thousand base pairs we're really
targeting DNA input of 150 KB so so this
so the other the other library prep
method which is common to nanopore
sequencing ligation libraries comes back
into play because we don't want to if
we're able to extract DNA up to fifty
fifty thousand base pairs and we will
try to maximize all
we don't want to insert [ __ ] insertion
site in the genome of fragmented more
using a transpose a so we go back to the
traditional method of ligation libraries
which originally we avoid it because
what we thought what we noticed was that
during the bead cleanup using amp exp
boots there was quite a high degree of
fragmentation and that resulted in even
if it had a high molecular weight input
that resulted in quite short fragments
being
due to due to shearing basically during
the cleanup but if you're starting with
the shorter input and there's also the
additional fact that we've now managed
to come up with ways to avoid doing bead
cleanups at all which is which was
pioneered by someone called John Tyson
in Vancouver who discovered a way of
using peg and salt precipitation to
avoid the use of ampere beads Sam pure
beads actually work on peg and salt on a
peg and salt precipitation principle
anyway but instead of using the solid
phase of of a bead we're he using some
precipitation by spinning in the
centrifuge so he's able to produce the
ligation library without any beads tool
and found that you could really maximize
the read length from that method so our
idea was that we could apply ligation
libraries and try to generate high
molecular weight DNA from stool as
possible we could we could achieve
higher yields on the Promethean so
that's what we that's what we set about
to do now it's very important when
you're doing any kind of microbiome
research to have to have standards for
validation and that's not just to
validate pretty no validation that your
that your method has worked but also for
can be important in development of
extraction methods but also downstream
analysis methods such as assembly and
taxonomic classification and these are
commonly called mock communities so the
the mock community that we need chose
was a commercially available product
called as I'm a microbial community
standard and that comes in two types
even and log distributed the even
contains contains the even number even
representation of a bacterium even
representation of two fungi the log is
is more to simulate and a real real
microbiome sample where there's a large
there's a large degree of difference
between the maple it's at least in the
most abundant
organisms in the mixture so this this
deal of distribution contains cells from
ten to two two and ten ta so over six
months of difficult difference there's
three I mentioned briefly earlier
there's it's important to know that
you're one of the big factors success of
an extraction procedure is whether it
works on gram-negative gram-positive and
fungi and in order to prove that you
need you need you need to have mixture
you need to have a mixture of these
different organisms in your in your
validation sample so this one contains
appropriately a few gram negatives some
gram positives and also some fungi and
the absol species of our Pseudomonas
which know the coli salmonella this
lactobacillus cementum Penta Cox for
Karla staph aureus Listeria
monocytogenes bacillus Attalus and then
the two yeast Saccharomyces cerevisiae
and Cryptococcus neoformans so it's a
good good range of organisms in there
consensually classified as cellular both
packing type cells except the fact that
in order to be in in order to inactivate
it for shipping this ship from something
called DNA and RNA DNA / RNA shield
which actually does cause some lysis
especially in the gram negative
organisms so when we do this we make
sure that we retain the supernatant if
you like so if you were to pellet it out
you would Palace themselves but also
it's important to retain the supination
because that that will contain some DNA
from from from gram negatives organisms
have lized
so yes and me and there's also an
Illumina data available for for the for
the proteins so we we've recently
published our results using using the
microbial standard basically even analog
and sequencing on the Oxford nanopore
Promethean instrument and this is
actually the first period be publication
which contains data produced by the
provider premiered on instruments which
is so it's very cutting edge
and the fever some some basic run
statistics though the the the plotter
plot a show shows a collective curve of
data generated so the the so they're
permitted the the the log and the even
community on the comedian generated in
excess of 160 gigabytes in a ninety hour
run or longer the to lower down curves
show them show the share the min iron or
the grits actually the gridiron to close
cells which we did and you can see that
they generate about 15 to 20 Giga bases
per gram the figure on the right shows
the even and the log communities for
both the gridiron on the Promethean and
you can see the in terms of accuracy the
modal accuracy of the of the instruments
is in excess of 90 percent and and and
very consistent between both the base
for two nanopore platforms and basically
two communities would be even the log so
it's also that so that's something that
we that were able to to really is a
validation that we are able to perform
from the log community we can also we
can also produce alignment statistics
for each of the organisms against the
reference Union for both the both the
Promethean and the gridiron and you can
see that the diagonal line represents
the expected abundance of those
organisms and you can see that the from
the year from the alignments artistics
they fall very nicely and tightly along
the diagonal line which means basically
that we're sequencing the expected
proportions that we are we hoping to and
that tells you that you're you're not
introducing any biases in easing the
extraction or the seating or the
inductance the analysis procedure and in
this particular case we're doing B
beeping which is gone on the entire song
on the entire sample so you wouldn't
expect it to be very much bias
this is a table showing the same same
data and you can for the log community
and you can see that for the highest for
the high bun London organism in the low
community for Listeria monocytogenes
we've got thirty six thousand eight
hundred X coverage for the Promethean
data and then for the next six organisms
we have up to we have xx coverage which
we return to be sufficient to assemble
the the genome and then below that we
have 2x coverage for the lactobacillus
cementum which is nothing which is
enough data to just to identify genes
subset of the teams and some genome
scale information but not enough to
assemble and then below that for the for
Carla's Amir Foreman's and the aureus we
have detectable quantities but very very
low not enough to find very much
information out that the organism but
just enough to detect it so you can see
that even with the vast equal power of
the premier ion we were able to we're
still able to be to be stumped by this
six logs of abundance but this really
represents the sort of state of the art
at the moment and it works over a fairly
wide range but we're only able to detect
the lowest input which was the staph
aureus which represented about 400 cells
in the in the sixty library which was
only one piece gram so we're able to
detect all the organisms six out of ten
organisms at high enough coverage to
assemble to to preserve some some
implements and genome scale information
and one sorry one to preserve some to
provide some genome scale information
and then three to provide just to be
detected
so the next section is about using the
community to optimize our extraction
methods for for improved poor increase
read length in the first section first
the first line I'm going to present here
is maybe a little bit controversial but
I think it's important to note that what
I did in this experiment was I took the
microbial community and I used the same
the same license procedure but then I
took the live site and I split it
between a spin column and a magnetic
bead extraction and in sequence them
both and what you see here is that the
spin column causes so much shearing down
down to ten kicks down to ten thousand
base pairs sort of maximum that you can
get in the previous spin column
extraction but even though you have this
potential you know this these long these
long fragments in your life states
because there's too much sheep with so
much shearing caused by the by the spin
column procedure that you're limiting a
reason to about ten thousand base pairs
so I make the slightly bold statement
here the spin columns to not do not
support long reads in this particular
application I would recommend the use of
magnetic bead base cleanup in this case
which would which will allow you to to
to recover up to thirty thousand base
pair DNA fragments
and and the the kit the kit this is that
these keys this is a very able to make a
very sort tightly controlled comparison
here due to the fact that sigh mode make
these two kits and mag bead kit and spin
column kit with the same binding
chemistry so these beads are silat these
are silica beads and these the same
binding chemistry is spin column so
you're able to split the light plate and
it's very tightly controlled experiment
so I mentioned I've already briefed and
talked about the differences in the cell
wall compositions of different organisms
but this really is the crux of the
problem which is that you get a very
wide diversity of bacteria lateral
species in your in your pinion real
clinical samples and they have very
different collisions so the bacterial
gram positive bacteria have a tough cell
wall but in both gram-positive and
gram-negative bacteria can also have an
additional capsule layer then if you're
if you're looking at microbial community
you're also going to have yeasts which
can have been very tough beat the gluten
or tightness layers protecting them and
you can also have spore-forming bacteria
which can have a spore cortex of
peptidoglycan and also they can have a
keratin case so these very very stable
difficult molecules to disrupt in
addition an infant as well as that they
also have a very wide range of chemical
compositions which makes which major
digestion quite couldn't quite a
challenging procedure but a catalyst
there's got types who should take most
the credit for this work has developed
something called meta qualify for the
ABR F meta genomics research group which
is a cocktail six enzymes
and you might have heard of deer of DNA
extraction enzymes in terms of sort of
common ones such as lysozyme but what he
did was cocktail together six enzymes
meet analyzing chroma peptidase lytic a
bridesmaid license baffling lysozyme
together in a single buffer where they
will have activity and and what that
will do is sort attack the broadest
possible spectrum of chemical
compositions of cell walls in bacterial
yeast and what what that will do is
digest the way the cell wall were
leaving only the living in your cell or
the plasma membrane bound cell which is
either a sterile class or approach
plaster gram negative and positive
organisms and then that leaves it to be
very susceptible to a [ __ ] to a chemical
licensed by detergent so we can use the
we can use avoid Stamkos or shearing
physical disruptions such as be beating
but in favor of gentle enzymatic
digestion in order to recover riff in
order to recover longer fragments of DNA
and that's really the basis behind how a
method we should call the three peaks
methods so when we take a real sample or
i mean or the autumn or community or
them for a particular a real sample but
we expose it to three sequential methods
of chemical enzymatic and physical
license increasing increasing harshness
effectively and what we do is we remove
the DNA that lets be able to recover at
each individual step so it doesn't get
damaged by the subsequent step say for
example after chemical lysis we spin
down the remaining cells take off the
supernatant put it to one side then we
take all the remaining cells we we
expose them to an enzymatic digestion
with metal polish i'm and then we spin
that down and anything that's still
anything any cells that are still
remaining at the end we exposed to to
physical disruption of be beating which
is going to cause quite severe DNA
fragmentation
but it will maintain the representation
that's the crucial thing you can't trade
off your fragment lengths for your your
representation because you have to know
what's in your sample even if you can't
recover long forever high molecular
weight DNA from it this is the
experiment here where we show you
abundances of God the organisms in the
mock community okay with different
treatments so the red is the is the
supernatant and the B beeping the green
is the supernatant and the Metropolitan
treatment and then the blue is the
supernatant and let the polygon kinda be
beating a full three-piece method and
what you can see notably is that the
without the be beating we lose the
representation of the Cryptococcus so
that has Cryptococcus neoformans is very
underrepresented 25 X under effect 25 x
times underrepresented when we're going
to be beating and in this particular
case this is an excellent example of the
validation data showing you that in this
case the strain of Cryptococcus
neoformans in the mix was not
susceptible to the digestion by the
Metropolitan
this here should be optimized the
extraction method that we developed
using a magnetic bead but also three
pigs together showing that we were able
to we're able to sequence the mic to
produce DNA from the microbial community
with an m50 of nearly twenty six
thousand base pairs so that's that's the
combination of using the of the
splitting out the extraction to put to
preserve the fragment length and with
the three peaks and then doing the
cleanup isolation using the magnetic
bead which we can magnetic bead which we
found to be able to preserve DNA but we
call that the optimized method from them
and we also assembled these these the
data set and this is done using a
program called fly which is a sort of
most recent generation and single
molecule assembler these will repeat
graphic and using a repeat graph
algorithm and to be honest the the
assembler is so good that we this is the
efficiency non-optimized
data so this is showing the comparison
between the original key designs dataset
which was just gonna be beaten and then
the optimized method which was the three
peaks and a beat and the magnetic bead
extraction and really the assembler is
doing such a good job even on the beat
beating that you don't see so much
difference here with these bacterial
species but if we look at the youth
obviously it's a larger genome
containing you know considerable numbers
of repeats you start to see here that
the optimized method with the long
fragment is generating larger context
for the first click for the footage each
species particularly doing sacrifices
service CI here for these dot we don't
have the data for these because it's all
of the ten species because we didn't
have a reference genome for all of these
in order to produce this dot plot we
need to be able to have a reference
genome so we have the sacrum Isis there
we also like to draw your attention to
that video if you're interested in
learning more about fly and how the
algorithm works there's a video on the
long read Club YouTube channel which is
youtube.com posed masculine read club
and and that that is that that's a good
that's a good resource for us that we've
started to compile information on long
beach sequencing and now i'm going to
show here a slide which contains our all
of our fecal vehicle extraction
Promethean and min and data that we have
so far and these are the real clinical
samples so they're the end fifties here
there are a lot shorter than the twenty
six thousand base pairs which were able
to achieve with the optimized method on
the more community but still very since
we were still able to generate and 50s
up to since up to nearly seventeen
thousand base pairs but some of these
real clinical samples which is that you
know we're very happy with because you
know this is a this is a real real real
clinical sample containing you know
complex clinical sample difficult to
work with and real feelings rather than
just a cellular and what community and
we're still able to generate and some
really nice long some really nice long
reads with with this method AB seventeen
value based pairs and you can see that
the yields are also going very high some
of these Promethean runs we have to in
excess of 100 110 Giga bases but this is
giving you the length and the yield
required to do to assemble these and do
some really fine detailed analysis of
these communities and to illustrate the
the three peaks method again this is a
histogram of the Redlands showing what
the actual read lens look like if you do
this so we do the you can see from the
histogram there is only really two peaks
and that's because and that's because
the chemical light is probably from the
first step and the methyl Polly's are
liquid both which is quite long DNA of
twenty sort of twenty to fifty k
kilobases and those those distributions
overlap so they appear to be one on the
cornice plots and then you see the B
beeping which is where you cut the cells
inside of a tube containing a matrix of
particles which can be eaten to you know
God mineral like garnet things like that
and then you explain it's a very high
energy using a using a be beating spin
which is a reciprocating or figure of
eight you know they could be the beads
around the tube causes that sort of
physical disruption that's smashing open
at the cells and some of these
instruments are extremely powerful they
the this is proper be beating if you
know using a fast purple something like
that needs to use the sample it's or six
meters/second or something it's very
sort of a very look person very large
amount of energy that you're putting in
that sample in fact if you be be at
something for about one minute take the
T values is hot touch that's how much
friction these beads cause and so that's
that's why you're able to preserve that
representation because you're you're
really using using a very large amount
of energy to disrupt these cells
just would like to say that the
colleagues for the US audience the three
peaks challenge which isn't named after
is actually a sort of the United Kingdom
center cent centric outdoors challenge
which is actually to visit the largest
that the tallest picniced Horace
mountains in in England Wales and
Scotland in the 24-hour period
so the the future perspectives and sort
of as a summary for this talk and we
lent a relatively short when using the
conventional be beating or column based
extraction methods we've developed ways
to avoid the pitfalls of be beating and
both column by changing to the three
peaks which has the chemical in the
enzymatic life is beforehand and also
moving to the mag be based extraction
methods and that's and that's shown nice
improvements into Freddie lamps which
are actually going to produce better
results when you do long leap sequencing
with them we found that met the polygon
with an important component in this
being able to produce long DNA from from
from all of the grand positives
organisms in the mock community also
wanted the yeast and the mock community
and we think that that's an important an
important method going forward we're
actually there's actually going to be a
meta polygon 2.0 in the pipeline which
we're going to be involved in the
spec'ing out and the production or
optimized extraction can get very long
read on nanopore sequencing and content
and that converts into highly contiguous
assemblies and when the yields on
Promethean are now sufficient over 100
Giga bases for patterning complex
community such as such as the such as
the 53 human gut microbiome project the
yields however sorry the inputs required
for a meeting place I only ordered 500
2009 grams and but you can produce that
with some 100 milligrams of solitude and
that's what that's what we do it's not a
large amount and we're able to recover
genome scale information over a range of
four logs using it with chip with yields
like this and detection of organisms
over six look
and all of the data dye produced that
I've talked about today is all available
on the online
this is all open data open analysis and
quite work as a postdoc in Nicol omens
lab this is the github for the laymen
lab and all of the work here is under a
page called the called ma community
then finally I'd like to acknowledge my
colleagues at the University of
Birmingham and Sam Nichols who did a lot
of this work in terms of the analysis
and squat ties he's developed and helped
us out a lot with the Metropolitan work
John Tyson's who developed me the beat
free method our contacts at Oxford
nanopore
and so I'm no research these
technologies I've mainly talked about
today and kind of Donald for providing
me with their the Mott community that's
the diamond distributor in the UK
and that's the end of my talk thank you
listening
you
well hello and thank you for joining us
today for the Simon research webinar my
name is dr. Jana McCormick and I'm the
director of microbiome applications at
Simon research today's topic is how we
can explore the microbiome with
confidence using microbiome excrete tool
and standard those tools can help
improve the accuracy and reproducibility
of microbiome measurements you probably
already know what the microbiome is it's
the study of microbial communities the
study of microbial ecosystems that live
everywhere around us and from the first
idea of a living cell that was described
by Robert Hooke in 1665 microbiologists
have been discovering this whole world
of microbes that surround us in an ever
fast faster growing space pace from the
first notion that microbes can ferment
food and produce beer and cheese to the
understanding that bacteria cause
diseases many of the techniques that
were developed in the Golden Age of
microbiology in the late eighteen
hundreds are still being used today for
medical diagnostics such as gram
staining or the petri dish but the
biggest push for the field really came
with the discovery of the DNA helix and
the discovery of the 16s RNA night
marker suddenly we found out there's
this whole kingdom of life that we
didn't know about before because
microbes cannot be because most of the
microbes cannot be grown in the lab the
sequencing technologies developed faster
and faster from the first bacterial
genome being sequenced in 1995 to the
human microbiome project and ocean
sampling day now
we know that there are about 10 to the
20 microbes on earth and about 100
trillion microbes on each of us however
99% of those microbes are not culturable
in the lab yet they have a huge impact
on our lives
the tools to study which microbes are
present and what they are doing on a
large high
fruit scale are referred to as
metagenomics and next generation
sequencing this time this term next
generation sequencing or short NGS can
be a bit misleading as Andrea's was
actually developed about 15 years ago
and we are now in the era of third
generation sequencing and with the
development of NGS and decrease in
sequencing cost and sequencing time
researchers started studying everything
from the oceans to our pets to ourselves
to agriculture and even the highest
points on earth researchers have been so
excited about the possibilities that NGS
has offered them that the microbiome
expelled has grown nearly three-fold by
the numbers of citations since 2005 with
more than 7,000 new publications per
year
one of the leading scientists in the
field is dr. Chris Mason from well
Cornell Medicine
he's one of my most closest
collaborators and he's really doing
amazing work analyzing the microbiome of
cities that we live in in tracing
microbes as well as antibiotic resistant
TSA's and he says that it's indeed an
exact and exciting time for the field of
metagenomics and the microbiome but
there's also limited ability to compare
between different research studies which
has greatly hindered the progress of
research and what he means by that I
would like to illustrate in two examples
you might have heard about the story
before as it came out in 2012 a
researcher collected her own fecal
sample and split it into two and then
she sent the two samples to two major US
companies that offered people microbiome
analysis and compared the results which
are shown here on this slide and the
results were drastically different both
profiles agree that the Bacteroidetes
and Firmicutes are the dominant phyla in
her sample but American gut showed that
the abundance of Bacteroides is much
higher than that of the firmicutes but
the you biome profile shows the complete
opposite the abundance of the firm acute
is much higher so just wants them just
one single sample to dramatically
different microbial profiles by two big
players in the field and what you need
to know is that these both companies use
very different protocols to process and
analyze the sample but still we don't
know which one is correct and while that
was just a single sample this example
highlights the drastic impact at
different protocols health on the
microbiome profile these are some of the
largest microbiome studies yet conducted
looking at the human fecal microbiome
the human microbiome project on the left
and metahit on the right the human
microbiome project alone had funding of
200 million u.s. dollars but just like
before the results are drastically
different even
if we're looking at just high taxonomic
levels like the phylum and they again
are reporting the opposite results
regarding the ratio of the bacteria DTS
and Firmicutes again both projects use
different protocols and we don't know
which results are true
and when we take a more detailed look at
the microbiome its workflow it's not
surprising that the results can be so
drastically different when using
different protocols as each step of the
workflow can have a huge impact on the
final result I will go over the major
causes that introduce this bias to the
microbiome measurements the first major
driver of bias is the sample collection
and storage keep in mind that you are
collecting living organisms that are
highly diverse some organisms may decay
or keep growing in your sample and
that's what I'm illustrating here they
are so diverse it's like trying to store
and ship dry ice cubes versus rocks with
a spread one may disappear really fast
others are quite stable and others may
start molding and decaying and to
illustrate what this means even major
publications like the American gut
project struggle with things like this
here's an example of a fecal sample and
it's not protected and we're just
looking at a higher phylum level and you
already see a big difference from they
want the e 0 to day one where there is
this pink growth on top and these are
Ecoline and e-coli can drastically it
grow very fast in your sample
and like I said even major publications
faced the challenge of sample collection
and the bacterial growth and decay of
nucleic acid degradation compromised
microbiome measurements in this case of
the American gut there was
there was an increase of e.coli
introduced by the sample collection and
it required editing of the data to retry
and remove bacterial brooms of e.coli
artificially from the data after the
samples were already collected and
processed those issues can be avoided
though llama research has developed DNA
RNA preservative called DNA RNA shield
that prevents this from happening and
can preserve the DNA for up to one year
at room temperature so now that we know
that we can store our samples without
worrying that any changes to the
microbiome a cure the next step is the
DNA and RNA extraction again we are
dealing with microbes that are highly
diverse with many diverse
characteristics some are easy to light
like e.coli others are difficult to
lifelike Listeria with different cell
sizes just like this example you might
need different tools to break open an
egg
versus a marble if you don't lyse the
cells the DNA of those organisms won't
get sequenced and the organisms are
underrepresented in your samples so
depending on which lysis method you use
like beat beating or chemical Isis the
results are very different this is one
of the major reasons why the results
from the human microbiome project and
metahit are so different the
over-representation of easy to lyse
organisms this is something you should
particularly pay attention to when
choosing your protocol I don't have time
to go into details today but Laemmle
research has also developed DNA and RNA
extraction kits that can avoid this type
of bias
by it and the library prep can be
introduced based on varying GC content
PCR inhibitors the formation the from
the formation of chimera or the primer
design itself which may not cover all
organisms in your sample the sequencing
platforms themselves also have some
sequencing errors associated with them
and finally the by informatics pipelines
that are using can have a huge impact as
well depending on how the alignments the
chimera removal the clustering are
handled to name just a few of them and
of course which reference database
you're using except I cannot put it
relatively minor alterations in the DNA
extraction procedure or in the
bioinformatics analysis can give a
distorted view and none of these steps
in the workflow are trivial but the
workflow is complex and prone to error
many products and methods have not been
validated for microbiome work simply
because those tools were never designed
for microbiome or NGS work many buffers
for the extraction never needed to be as
clean as we need them to be now because
sequences can start picking up bacteria
that were added to your sampled simply
because they were already present in the
buffers so this is very particular to
ensure that your buffers are clean
with the record growth of the microbiome
field they have been consequences the
accuracy and reproducibility of issues
are rampant and we know about those
issues and this paper was published in
2015 but four years later the results
are still the same and the requirements
are still the same for every PCR that
you run you need a positive and a
negative control but for microbiome
experiments there is currently no such
requirement by any journals and Costilla
at all did an extensive comparison
between different studies comparing 21
of the most cited different DNA
extraction protocols and here I'm
listing some of their highlighted
findings they found that the product
Hall used dramatically dramatically
influenced the conclusions taken from
comparative studies every step from
simple sample collection and storage to
the extraction methods used had a huge
impact on the outcome so the variation
between protocols was larger than the
variation between subjects and they are
not the only ones that have been looking
into this and they're now several more
studies that have been published and
look specifically at this problem of
bias between different studies and
extraction protocol
but we as researchers rely on other
publications to conduct and do our own
research for every grant proposal every
paper we write we put our own research
into reference what other people have
been publishing and this has great
consequences on our own work so let's
just look at a very simplified example
let's say study a claims we found a
large gym which is pretty amazing and
everyone is excited but then study B
says hey we found this small gym and
when you start comparing those two
studies those two gems look pretty much
alike
that is it now a large one or a small
one and how can we compare those results
especially now that we know that every
single step of the protocol can have a
huge impact on the results but how can
we draw any conclusions without using a
reference because measurements are
always relative but once we add a scale
to the findings we can actually start
comparing the results of course there
are different kinds of scales that we
could use in some may be more
appropriate than others and even in the
history of our world we haven't quite
been able to just agree on a single
scale to measure something like distance
but ideally we can agree on just one or
two scales for microbiome measurement so
we can translate the findings and
communicate our results clearly with one
another because keep in mind every
single step of the workflow influences
the outcome and even change the
perspective of the microbiome that we
and the results we find
and I hope that I've convinced you that
using a standard for microbiome studies
is needed Saima research has now
developed multiple standards that can
help you identify if there is any bias
in your workflow all the way from sample
collection and preservation to the by
automatic analysis this is what's Lamaze
microbial community standard number one
looks like it's the more community of 10
different organisms 8 bacteria and 2
yeast in an even abundance these
organisms were specifically selected to
represent a wide variety of different
cell sizes toughness of the cell wall ng
GC content like you would find in a wide
variety of different samples this
standard can be used for general
benchmarking and microbiome profiling
the whole cell is the more community for
the complete workflow so everything from
sample collection DNA extraction and so
on and the DNA mo community is for the
library prep and bioinformatics
part of the pipeline
of course Akram accuracy matters here if
you want to benchmark your work to a
standard that standard has to be as
accurate as possible then resource
grantees that there is less than 15%
deviation from the defined composition
and less than 0.01 for in microbial DNA
contamination the same standard is also
available on a log scale to it to assess
the detection limit and sensitivity of
the workflow again it's provided as a
whole cell a mix or as the DNA mix lemma
has also developed spike in controls
this standard can be used as an internal
process control and enables absolute
quantification of microbes in a sample
so there is no need to run additional QP
CRS for example the standard is
available in high and low bacterial load
depending on the bio burden of the
sample you're using so you know exactly
how many cells of these two organisms
that we provide you're using as you can
see at the last step of your workflow
how much percent of those two organisms
do you find and you can calculate back
the absolute abundances of yourself so
this is a really great tool that saves
you a lot of time running without the
need to run additional QP CRS
the new standard that Lama has developed
is the human designer by omics
high-molecular-weight DNA standard that
was created to help validate long read
metagenomic tools and pipelines it's
composed of purified high molecular
weight DNA larger than 50 KB from seven
bacteria and one yeast as listed here
the taxonomic diversity can help with
the development and validation of long
read metagenomic bioinformatics tools
just like we heard dr. quick talked
about earlier as shown in this graph on
the left high quality read DNA data is
generated from the cyma by omics high
molecular weight DNA standard in the
Oxford nanopore minion sequencing run
shown here the histogram shows an
average read length of 24 KB and more
than 125 KB recorded
pizanno research is offering a control
for the entire microbiome mix workflow
to address every single step that could
you introduce bias into your data from
sample collection and preservation using
DNA RNA shield to using specific DNA and
RNA extraction methods based on your
sample type and needs to library
preparation kits and we also offer next
generation data sequencing analysis
so further apart ten minutes I have
described the immense challenges faced
by the field but also showed you that
there can be resolved final research has
built a complete pipeline for microbiome
studies and has resolved major workflow
challenges faced by customers I didn't
have time today to go into specific
details but I'm most offering a solution
for every step of the way providing
standard solutions for unbiased sample
collection unbiased DNA extraction
library preparation and data analysis we
are currently offering the microbiome
expanded and controls initiatives the my
side initiative you can simply tell us
about your project and we will provide
you with free standards that you can
incorporate into your workflow to see if
there is any bias in your workflow you
simply sign up on our website and we
will send you the more community
standards just as you needed and with
that I'm at the end of my presentation
and I would be happy to answer any
questions that you might have thank you
thank you doctor quick and dr. comeback
for your informative presentations we
will now start the Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen will answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for alright let's get started our first
question is how can the read length be
improved further
I think that's a good question
really what we're what we're talking
about is how do you improve from from
read length sort of sort of ten tens of
KB to to bridge the gap to what we what
were able to the ultra long reads which
were able to achieve which we're able to
achieve on on the on Burton gram
negatives and and human cells and that
is definitely not an easy time or for
many gram-positive spore and funghi i
think that really if you see that the
options we have really are our further
development of enzymatic approaches to
broaden the substrate specificity of
those to move to them to move to some
some entirely novel form or some
entirely look to explore other sort of
non-standard forms of cell lysis there
are some examples already of confusing
fruits no heat fighting or freak or
cracking cells open there's examples of
conscious on occasion being used to
disrupt cell membranes
really I think that collectors the
nesters and the script canisters and
some sort of some completely non
standard method of cell sort of cell
disruption and really we're talking
about further development or
optimization of chemical and enzymatic
methods
you alright the next question is how
will this help further understanding of
human disease
let's go back to this question goes back
to my introductory slide really and I
gave a couple of examples of projects
which were involved in here at
Birmingham the first being and the the
fecal transplantation clinical trials
and in that in the clinical trial we're
collecting fecal samples from day one of
the day of the recipient the receipt in
the donation of the transplantation and
then at day 56 of the transplantation
and what we're interested is how many
species persist to 56 days and a way
that we're doing that is by taking doing
shotgun metagenomics so extracting all
the DNA from the from those samples
assembling them and then then trying to
identify persistence of individual
strains and it's quite simple basic
analysis or either you might have done
in the park
I have introduced some sort of 16s which
will give you our genus or potentially
species level assignments or Illumina
short-short we've met genetics which
would potentially give you species level
assignments but but really what we're
talking about now the cutting edge is
whole genomes and strains and can we
identify you know strain level diversity
within a species give within a microbial
community and that's really that's
really where we're the hot ticket is
these days in order to further our
understanding of microbial communities
the dynamics at play and the
interactions with human disease
thank you it looks like we have time for
one more question are there any other
method methods for cell lysis in
development
and
so I I briefly I briefly mentioned a
couple of other methods that I knew
about and you know anything my answer to
the previous question so in addition to
to to chemical which using current based
lysis detergent based methods for
solubilizing membranes I also talked
about enzymatic methods from the
development of both broader broader
spectrum enzyme cocktails such as metal
paula zahn 2.0 and then I'd talked about
physical disruption methods which
normally which normally involve very
very very harsh physical physical
treatment such as a be beating Val then
I mentioned free saw processes where you
try to basically free the sample in
order to correct cell open via the
action of the expansion of water which
which expect which obviously expands
when it freezes
and also Agha sonication
methods as a sort of non-standard
approach towards towards sailed towards
disruption of microbial cells I can
think of a couple of other non-standard
methods such as cytotoxin soap or
forming proteins and similar to
menopause themselves actually but I've
been in it in a completely different
context any proteins which can puncture
their way through cell membranes could
be a one possible way of causing cell
lysis and to microbial peptides another
class of molecules which could
potentially be used in persons in the
same way
and
that's all I can think of at the moment
and your important research we would
also like to thank levers and our
sponsors Imoh research for rewriting
today's educational webcast before we go
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speakers
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration lab routes
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's event until
next time goodbye